Для безпеки Європи ми себе оголили.
То ядерна зброя Україні потрібна, Ви вважаєте? Навіщо?
Це не є закликом до повернення атомної зброї. Це аргументація на переговорах.
А Ви взагалі не вірите в мирний процес для Донбасу?
З Путіним? Ні. Путін не збирається миритися з Україною.
А як Ви особисто ставитеся до Путіна?
До Путіна? Це мій єдиний ворог.
І от сидячи тут, в Європарламенті, що Ви хотіли б йому сказати?
Нічого. Ми не ведемо переговорів з терористами.
Пане Сенцов, Ви довідалися, що Вам присудили премію Сахарова з листа.
Які емоції це у Вас викликало?
Це запитання мені ставлять дуже часто.
І, на жаль, у мене немає якоїсь гарної відповіді, що я радів, бігав і кричав від радощів.
Я тоді відходив після голодування, практично постійно лежав.
Тому це була якась далека подія, яка до мене тодішнього
не мала жодного особливого відношення.
Коли Вас нарешті звільнили, якою Ви побачили Україну? Це нова країна тепер?
На жаль, ні.
Те, що я бачив на Майдані, усі ці спроби змін, коли, якщо Ви там були і пам'ятаєте, два квартали…
Ми будували нову країну, там були зовсім інші стосунки, зовсім інший підхід,
зовсім інші люди були, наче якесь джерело світла.
І я би хотів, щоб це джерело поширилося на всю країну.
Воно почало розповзатися, але поки що ми ще
не змогли зламати систему, не змогли реформувати нашу країну і зробити ривок.
Ми поки що тупцюємо на місці.
Зрозуміло, що нам в ногу нині вчепилася Росія своєю пащекою, не відпускає нас.
Але крім цього, в нас є ще внутрішні проблеми, які ми досі не вирішили.
Тому в Україні відбулося нове голосування, змінився уряд, парламент.
Народ хоче змін. Побачимо, чи будуть вони.
Ви нещодавно сказали, що оскільки Росія забрала в України Крим,
то Україні повинні повернути ядерну зброю…
Розумієте, що це ніби така собі не реальна пропозиція,
а просто привід для переговорів… навіть не переговорів з Путіним, а аргументація.
Тому що він затягнув переговори - нормандський, мінський формат -
в кут загнав Україну, і вона намагається знайти вихід.
Не потрібно. Треба вийти просто з цього кута.
Сказати "ні". Це перемир'я було тимчасове,
і ми не маємо наміру це виконувати, тому що намагатися це зробити буде на шкоду Україні.
Потрібно відмотати назад і почати з того, з чого починали - з визнання кордонів України
в тих межах, які були підтверджені Будапештським меморандумом,
гарантами якого є США, Великобританія і Росія.
Тобто Росія повинна повернути те, що вона в нас забрала.
Як аргументація, що ми віддали за це бомбу, атомну зброю,
реальні боєголовки, які несли смерть всьому навколо.
Для безпеки Європи ми себе оголили.
Коли на нас напали, ми повинні відчувати колективну турботу про нас.
Але це турбота, а не захист.
То ядерна зброя Україні потрібна, Ви вважаєте? Навіщо?
Я вам так довго все пояснював, щоб ви мене зрозуміли,
що це не є закликом до повернення атомної зброї.
Це аргументація на переговорах, з чого все почалося, до чого ми маємо повернутися.
Ось ми це зробили, а Росія у нас забрала і не хоче дотримуватися домовленостей.
Ось до чого ця розмова, а не до повернення зброї, ви що?
Зрозуміло. А Ви взагалі не вірите в мирний процес для Донбасу?
З Путіним? Ні.
Він не збирається миритися з Україною, не збирається досягати миру на Донбасі,
він хоче кинути нам Донбас, як ярмо на шию Україні, і керувати звідти вже цілою країною.
А що Україні тоді робити?
Я не займаюсь ухваленням рішень на достатньому рівні. У нас є керівництво і уряд.
Я можу давати будь-які коментарі, будь-які прогнози, але який сенс?
А як Ви взагалі сприймаєте конфлікт між Росією та Україною?
Це конфлікт двох світоглядів, двох світів.
Один хоче жити в минулому, в Радянському союзі, який нині будує Путін, оновлена така модель.
Я живу давно і застав ще Радянський союз.
Нині відбувається те саме.
Я там п'ять років провів - дуже схоже.
І між людьми, які хочуть жити в майбутньому,
які хочуть будувати свою країну за європейськими принципами - свободи і рівності.
Але нам не дають. Тому ми за це і боремося.
Це конфлікт світоглядів, підходів, а не конфлікт народів. Це слід усвідомлювати.
Ви на собі відчули, що таке Росія Путіна. Розкажіть, як Ви її бачите, що це таке?
Росія Путіна?
Ну, по-перше, це держава, в якій не функціонує жодна інституція:
ні парламент, ні суди, ні поліція, ні громадянське суспільство, ні ЗМІ - нічого цього нема.
Є одна інституція на ім'я Володимир Путін - такий собі великий стержень, кілок,
вбитий глибоко в землю, на який спирається все інше, все залежить від нього, від його команди,
від його настрою, від його повороту, від його погляду, від його думки.
Вони намагаються вгадати, що він міг би подумати, і, виходячи з цього, функціонує вся країна.
Все підлаштовано під одну людину.
Тобто він настільки усе зробив у ручному режимі, на собі замкнув, тому це працює лише так.
Але з його відходом, зі смертю або усуненням від влади ця система почне руйнуватися,
тому що якщо цей стержень виймуть - все обвалиться.
Нічого немає незалежного.
І ось під час такого обвалу російського режиму з'явиться вікно можливостей
для вирішення наших проблем - Донбасу і Криму.
Реального вирішення. Не простих оцих розмов "бла-бла", а реальних рішень.
Ось до цього слід бути готовим - і Україні, і Європі, і світу,
щоб зайняти жорстку позицію щодо цих територій.
А як Ви особисто ставитеся до Путіна?
До Путіна? Це мій єдиний ворог.
І от сидячи тут, в Європарламенті, що Ви хотіли б йому сказати?
Нічого.
Ми не ведемо переговорів з терористами.
Ви говорили, що хотіли б бачити його на лаві підсудних в Гаазі.
Ось тепер в Гаазі триває розгляд позову України проти Росії.
Ваша мрія, таким чином, починає збуватися?
Ні, це зовсім не те, що я хотів би бачити.
За військові злочини проти України, за розв'язану війну, за 13 тисяч убитих,
за збитий Боїнг має бути особиста відповідальність цієї людини.
Як нюрнберзький трибунал, розумієте?
Там же судили людей, які самі людей не вбивали, вони ж нікого не повісили,
нікого не застрелили самі, але вони створювали систему, яка працювала на знищення мільйонів.
От і Путін створив систему, яка, слава Богу,
знищує лише тисячі, але ж це тисячі наших реально загиблих людей.
Тобто він - військовий злочинець.
А чи робить ЄС достатньо для того, щоб допомогти Україні протистояти цій агресії?
Ну, у ЄС свої завдання. Це організація, створена не для військового вирішення конфліктів.
Є НАТО, а ЄС - це мирне об'єднання, яке може лише чинити тиск за допомогою санкцій,
за допомогою якихось розмов, якихось політичних моментів.
А з Путіним це погано працює. Він теж у відповідь щось каже.
Всі одне одному щось кажуть, а що в підсумку?
Так, активна фаза війни припинилася, але не до кінця.
Це як конфорку газову скрутили на маленький вогонь,
але він продовжує горіти і продовжують гинути реальні люди щотижня.
А що НАТО тоді має робити більше?
Я ще раз повторю, з чого треба було починати тоді -
замість "нормандського формату" відновлювати "будапештський формат" і ці розмови вести.
Нас Путін затягнув туди, але тоді була активна фаза війни,
і Порошенко мусив піти на це,
тому що було пряме військове втручання Росії, ввели війська Росії, стріляли "гради" російські.
Тобто це вже не просто підтримка бойовиків добровольцями.
Це вже напряму російські військові частини там воювали у 2014-му році.
Це факт, який для всіх є очевидним.
А змушені були себе так вести, бо боялися Росії.
Ну от, отримуйте тепер…
Дякую Вам за інтерв'ю!